Sanyukai is a nonprofit, and its goal is to help the homeless...
...and former homeless around the area of Sanya, Tokyo's skid row.
Although as far as skid rows go,...
...I got to say, it's quite orderly and clean.
While Sanyukai only has ten staff, it has over 100 volunteers,...
...which include former homeless people themselves.
Beyond the free healthcare, food and temporary shelter they provide,...
...perhaps the most important aspect of their mission...
...is the personal connection they make with these mostly senior men.
While these men have all found shelter off the streets,...
...it wasn't always like that for them.
It's for that reason that Sanyukai makes meals on a daily basis,...
...where they sometimes serve over 100 people.
Once the meals are made, they take the food to a predetermined location,...
...today, under a highway, where people made up two lines to receive the food.
Everyone got a ticket, and five per line were sent to get their meals.